♪
>> Katie: 2020 DEMOCRATIC
FRONT RUNNER JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN UNDER FIRE FOR A STRING
OF GAFFES MADE ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
MOST RECENTLY RECEIVING
HEAVY CRITICISM AFTER
FAILING TO ACCURATELY TELL A
STORY ABOUT HIS ENCOUNTER
WITH A WAR HERO.
NOW, THE FORMER VEEP IS ON
THE DEFENSE.
>> THE DETAILS ARE
IRRELEVANT IN TERMS OF
DECISION-MAKING AND SO THE
FACT THAT I WOULD FORGET
THAT IT WAS RODRIGUEZ WHO
WAS PINNING -- I BELIEVE
THIS IS THE CASE -- PINNING
A BRONZE STAR ON A YOUNG MAN
WAS -- IT'S I. TO THE POINT.
I. -- IRRELEVANT
TO THE POINT.
LIKE SAYING I HAD THIS VERY
BRIGHT REPORTER, I THINK HER
EYES WERE BLUE.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE
IF YOU ARE A BRIGHT REPORTER
YOUR EYES ARE BROWN.
IT'S IRRELEVANT AND YOU KNOW
IT.
>> Katie: DANA, WINNING OR
LOSING?
DETAILS MATTER IF YOU ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> Dana: IT'S A LONG TIME.
IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN THAT'S
A LONG TIME TO BE THE
FRONTRUNNER.
TO BE HANGING ON AS THE
FRONT UNER 18 MONTHS.
NOBODY CAN LAY A GLOVE ON
HIM REALLY SO FAR IN THE
POLLS.
HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO.
>> Brian: HE KEEPS LAYING
GLOVES ON HIMSELF.
>> Dana: BERNIE SANDERS
LITERALLY DID THAT LAST
WEEK.
>> Brian: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Dana: INTERESTING THING
IS NOT THE GAFFE PEOPLE WHO
LIKE JOE BIDEN DON'T CARE.
THEY THINK THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
WHAT BIDEN DID THERE A
LITTLE BIT HE WALKED RIGHT
UP TO THE LINE OF CALLING IT
FAKE NEWS AND PUSHING BACK
ON THE MEDIA COVERAGE.
I'M SURE IS HE FRUSTRATED
WITH THE MEDIA.
BIG PIECE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" YESTERDAY OR SUNDAY
BY MARK LEASH VERY MUCH AND
ASKING HIM WHAT IS YOUR
RATIONALE TO BE PRESIDENT?
REALLY IT'S NOT SHARP IT'S
NOT THERE.
WELL, SOMEBODY HAS GOT TO
BEAT TRUMP.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS WHO
LOVE HIM ARE GOING TO STICK
WITH HIM.
THAT IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BE SOLID.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO END.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT THE
BERNIE SANDERS AND ELIZABETH
WARREN REPORTERS ARE LIKE
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
ELIZABETH WARREN IS POLLING
AT 1% WITH AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS.
THERE IS A BIG RECKONING TO
COME.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL COME
FOR A FEW MONTHS.
THE FACT THAT HE CAN'T
ACTUALLY NAIL DOWN HIS
ANSWER FOR WHY HE WANTS TO
BE PRESIDENT EXCEPT FOR
SOMEBODY HAS TO BEAT TRUMP
THAT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT'S
GOOD ENOUGH TO ME.
>> Brian: I WILL BUILD ON
WHAT YOU SAID, DANA.
HE WENT ON TO SAY IF ROMNEY
WAS RUNNING OR JEB WAS
PRESIDENT HE MIGHT NOT RUN.
SO, THEN HE SAID I'M THE
ONLY ONE ELECTABLE.
I'M DOING IF FOR THE PARTY.
BARACK OBAMA SAID YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DO.
THIS TODAY HE SAID I THINK 8
OR 10 OF THE OTHER DEMOCRATS
COULD BEAT TRUMP.
HE JUST UNDID HIS OWN
ARGUMENT.
WHAT I THINK IS MOST DAMNING
TWO THINGS.
HE WAS IN CHARGE OF PAYING
OUT THE STIMULUS PACKAGE AND
IN CHARGE OF THE PULLOUT OF
IRAQ.
IF YOU READ MATTIS' BOOK
TODAY HE TALKS ABOUT
INTERACTING WITH BIDEN
TRYING TO EXPLAIN THE
PROBLEMS IF YOU PULL OUT THE
WAY HE WANTS TO AND ALLOW
MALIKI TO STEAL THAT
ELECTION AND HE BASICALLY
GAVE HIM LIP SERVICE AND DID
IT ANYWAY AND WE KNOW WE GOT
ISIS IN RETURN.
THAT'S WHAT A PRESIDENT
BIDEN WOULD DO.
>> Jesse: I WOULD LIKE TO
BUILD ON THAT AS WELL,
BRIAN.
HE GETS THE DETAILS WRONG
AND THE DECISIONS WRONG.
GATES SAID JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN WRONG ON EVERY SINGLE
FOREIGN POLICY DECISION IN
THE LAST 40 YEARS.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, HE
WAS AGAINST REAGAN'S PUSH
AGAINST THE SOVIETS DURING
THE COLD WAR.
HE WAS AGAINST DESSERT
STORM.
HE WAS AGAINST THE SURGE.
HE WAS AGAINST THE BIN LADEN
RAID.
HE WAS FOR REGIME CHANGE IN
LIBYA.
FOR NAFTA.
YOU COULD ADD ALL THESE
THINGS UP.
WHEN YOU COMBINE THE GAFFES,
THE POOR DECISIONS, THE AGE
AND SLEEPINESS ON THE TRAIL,
IT IS A VERY NASTY MIX OF
NEGATIVES THAT IS GOING TO
DRAG HIM DOWN.
THE ONLY REASON IS HE UP
RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE WARREN
AND SANDERS ARE SPLITTING
THE LEFT WING VOTE AND HE
HAS GREAT NAME I.D.
OTHER THAN THAT, I THINK HE
IS THE WEAKEST FRONTRUNNER I
HAVE EVER SEEN AND HE MIGHT
LOSE IOWA AND NEW HAMPSHIRE
AND THAT LEAVES HIM WITH
THE.
>> Brian: SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> Jesse: LEAVES HIM WITH
WHOSE STRATEGY WAS THAT
RUDY'S WE ALL KNOW WHO THAT
WAS.
>> Dana: HIS WAS FLORIDA
GERALDO GERALDO I THINK YOU
ARE BEING KIND IN THE
BIOLOGY OF IT.
HE IS ONLY NINE MONTHS OLDER
THAN I AM.
>> Dana: JOE BIDEN?
GERALDO GERALDO JOE BIDEN.
>> Katie: HOW CAN I TELL?
>> Geraldo: IT'S THE HAIR.
WHEN HE MISSES THE BEAT, IT
REALLY SEEMS ORGANIC TO ME.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE IS
GOING TO GET SHARPER GOING
FORWARD.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO ME THAT
THIS IS JUST THE WARMING UP,
THAT HE IS GOING TO GET IN
THERE AND HE IS GOING TO BE
MORE ARTICULATE AND MORE
COMPETENT THAN HIS
PRESENTATION.
NOR ELOQUENT.
MORE PRESIDENTIAL IN A
SENSE.
HE SEEMS TENTATIVE TO ME.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
AROUND HIM LIKE THEY HOPE HE
DOESN'T BREAK, YOU KNOW.
AND.
>> Brian: TRUMP WANTS TO
MAKE SURE HE DOESN'T BREAK.
I THINK TRUMP WANTS HIM TO
BE HIS OPPONENT.
>> Katie: BRIAN, THE
ARGUMENT WITH JOE BIDEN
BEING THE FRONTRUNNER IS
THAT HE IS STRONG HE IS THE
ONE WHO HAS THIS IN THE BAG.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO GOING
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
JUGGERNAUT AND JOE BIDEN
CLEARLY NOT REALLY WANTING
IT CONSIDERING THAT HE IS
SAYING THAT HE MAYBE
WOULDN'T BE IN IT IF IT
WASN'T PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HIS WIFE HAVING A HARD TIME
SELLING HIS PLAN SAYING, YOU
KNOW, HIS PLAN MIGHT NOT BE
THE BEST ONE.
HE MIGHT NOT BE THE BEST
CANDIDATE BUT YOU SHOULD
ELECT HIM TO BEAT DONALD
TRUMP, IS HE REALLY GOING TO
BE ABLE TO KEEP UP IT COMES
TO TAKING CAMPAIGN OFF OF
HIS SCHEDULE RIGHT NOW WHEN
HE IS NOT IN A HARD BATTLE
FOR THE FRONT RIGHT NOW.
>> Brian: WAIT UNTIL NEXT
WEEK'S DEBATE.
EVERY TIME HE GOES INTO
DEBATE IN A NON-SCRIPTED
SITUATION.
IT'S A CARNIVAL OF FAUX
PASS.
WE CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Dana: ALSO SEE IF ONE OF
THE OPPONENTS GOES AFTER
HIM.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE BECAUSE
HE IS A GAFFE MACHINE.
IT WILL BE BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING LIKE HIS COZINESS
WITH THE CREDIT CARD
INDUSTRY.
GERALDO GERALDO IF HE LOSES
NEW HAMPSHIRE AND IOWA, WHAT
HAPPENS?
>> Katie: THAT'S THE
QUESTION?
IS HE GOING TO LOSE THE
MOMENTUM AT THE FRONT.